en este vídeo vamos a ver la
clasificación y nomenclatura de
alcoholes aquí tengo mi alcohol genérico
en la parte de arriba tengo mi grupo
alquilo a la izquierda y tengo un bache
a la derecha que se llama grupo
hidroxilo veamos la clasificación de
nuestros alcoholes entonces si tengo un
carbono unido a un h y ese carbono está
unido a otro carbono en este grupo al
kilo de aquí se dice que eso es un
alcohol pri mario
este carbono de aquí está unido a los
carbonos en esos dos grupos al kilo por
lo que es un alcohol
secundario
y luego este carbono en la derecha está
unido a otros
carbonos y por eso se dice que es un
alcohol terciario
demos un vistazo a la nomenclatura de
alcoholes empecemos con unas moléculas
simples así que si tengo una molécula
que se ve así
y quiero nombrarlo utilizando una
nomenclatura iupac quiero enumerar mi
cadena de carbonos para darle a s
el menor número posible entonces este
carbono será el número uno este carbono
tendrá el número dos y este carbono será
el número tres ahora si ese o h no
estuviera ahí entonces tendríamos un
arcano de tres carbonos al cual
llamaríamos propano pero ya que tenemos
él
es de hecho un alcohol un alcohol va de
hecho a tener la terminación o l así que
esto se llama propanol así que
escribamos propano la aquí
pero
lores
y el grupo h sale del carbono 1 así que
diremos que es 1 propanol de esta manera
como clasificamos este alcohol bueno el
carbono es carbono que está aquí unido
al h ese carbono está unido a este otro
carbono de aquí así que esto va a ser un
alcohol primario así que 1 propanol es
un alcohol primario en términos de su
clasificación veamos una molécula que se
ve bastante similar también son 3
carbonos pero esta vez ponemos la o h en
el carbono de en medio así que otra vez
vamos a enumerar lo
entonces este es el carbono 1 este es el
carbono 2
este es el carbono 3
es un alcohol de 3 carbonos también se
llama
pero
no hoy
la diferencia es que el grupo hidroxilo
está en otro carbono verdad ahora está
en el carbono 2 así que vamos a escribir
2 propano la aquí que es un nombre iupac
también llamado isopropanol alcohol para
frotar todos se refieren a lo mismo pero
dos propano sería sería la nomenclatura
iupac apropiada como clasificaría 2
propanol una vez más encontramos al
carbono unido al h que es este y a
cuántos carbonos está unido este carbono
está unido a 1
2 carbonos por lo tanto esto es un
alcohol secundario así que tenemos un
ejemplo de alcohol primario y un ejemplo
de alcohol secundario aquí
hagamos una pregunta un poco más difícil
por lo que dibujemos una molécula más
larga
con más sustituyen test
así que pongamos un y aquí luego hagamos
algo como
esto y luego hagamos algo así también
así que daremos el nombre iupac completo
para esta molécula entonces queremos
encontrar la cadena de carbonos más
grande que incluya el lo h así que
queremos la cadena de carbonos más larga
que incluya el h y quieres dar al h el
menor número posible
eso significa que vas a empezar aquí
haremos a este el carbono número 1 de
esta manera así que este es el carbono
número uno este deberá ser el carbono
número 2
7 por lo que tenemos un alcohol de 7
carbonos un alcohol de 7 carbono sería
un etanol así que podemos empezar a
nombrar esto y cerciórese de dejar mucho
espacio aquí así que tenemos
y sabemos que el bache está saliendo del
carbono número dos así que tenemos 2
etanol como esto
veamos a los otros sustituye entes que
tenemos bueno que tenemos
que tenemos aquí saliendo de nuestro
carbono 3
tenemos un grupo alquilo de 3 carbonos
eso sería propio entonces tenemos 3
propios así que escribiré
pero
aquí como esto y luego que más tenemos
en el carbono 5 tenemos 2 sustituye
entes entonces tenemos tenemos un grupo
cloro aquí y tenemos un grupo metil aquí
y recuerda el alfabeto así que la sede
está antes de la m así que podemos
continuar y agregar metil saliendo del
carbono 5 así que tenemos 5
me til
y también saliendo en el número 5
tenemos el cloro así que tenemos 5
cloro
justo aquí y eso debería de hacer que
todo siga el orden alfabético así que
tenemos 5 cloro sin cometer tres propios
2 sept and all para esta molécula
qué tal les parece un problema que
contenga estéreo química les parece así
que digamos que nos dan uno en el que
nos tenemos que preocupar por la estéreo
química aquí así que continuemos y
dibujemos otra cadena
veamos
algo como
y dibujemos un grupo
h
alejándose de nosotros y luego hagamos
este
viniendo hacia nosotros de esta manera
bien entonces el nombre iupac completo
para esta molécula y una vez más tienes
que incluir estéreo química así que una
vez más encuentra tu cadena de carbonos
más larga que incluye a tu grupo h y
quieres dar a ese o h el menor número
posible y tiene prioridad sobre otros
grupos como grupos al kilo y luego
halógenos y enlaces dobles así que
empezaremos desde la izquierda
así que tenemos uno
9 justo así así que tenemos un alcohol
de 9 carbonos eso sería un no nano lee y
el alcohol está saliendo del carbono 3
el h está saliendo del carbono 3
entonces tenemos
no
no como esto 3 no nano y veamos cuáles
son los otros sustituye entes bueno en
el carbono 6 tenemos en el carbono 6 de
aquí tenemos un sustituyen td 2 carbonos
eso sería un grupo de ti así que
continuemos y pongamos 6 active así que
tenemos 6
con un guión entre ellos así que hasta
ahora tenemos 6 731 nano
y tenemos que preocuparnos de tenemos
que preocuparnos de estéreo química
verdad así que si ponen diagramas de
cuñas en un problema necesitas pensar
necesitas pensar en estéreo química y de
hecho pones esas configuraciones
absolutas en el inicio del nombre yu
para que trabajemos primero con la
estéreo química del carbono 3 antes que
nada de acuerdo entonces la estéreo
química del carbono 3
este es nuestro estéreo centro justo
aquí este carbono y otra vez vas a los
átomos que están conectados directamente
con tu estéreo centro los cuales son
carbono carbono oxígeno
y también tenemos saliendo de nuestro
estéreo centro también tenemos un
hidrógeno
que se sale hacia nosotros de esta
manera esa sería la menor prioridad eso
tendrá un número 4 aquí por lo que el
oxígeno es el que tiene mayor número
atómico por lo que tendrá el número 1
y luego tenemos otra cadena por aquí
para este carbono a la derecha por lo
que tendrá el número
tenemos el número
y luego el hidrógeno será el número 4
hay un pequeño truco que mostré en un
vídeo anterior así que parece si ignoras
el hidrógeno parece que va a ir en
sentido en este sentido parece como si
fueras en sentido antihorario parece que
es ese
pero
pero tienes pero tienes esto esto bajo
en prioridad saliendo hacia ti
así que recuerda el truco era que parece
que es cc con esos tres y ahora revierte
el sentido así que debe ser r debe tener
una configuración absoluta de r en el
carbono tres así que continuemos y
escribamos aquí adentro
r y luego tenemos que preocuparnos de la
configuración absoluta en el carbono 6
así que en el carbono 6 de aquí así que
este es otro exterior centro hay cuatro
diferentes sustituye entes unidos a él
también hay un hidrógeno unido a este
carbono alejándose de nosotros como esto
y pensemos en la mayor prioridad esta
cadena a la izquierda está esta cadena
va a tener una mayor prioridad
hay más carbonos en esta de la derecha
así que una vez más cuando a signes
prioridades esta va a tener la más alta
y luego esta y la tercera es esta de
aquí así que esta vez vas a ir alrededor
de 123 vamos a ir en sentido antihorario
pero tu grupo de menor prioridad tu
grupo de menor prioridad que es este
hidrógeno de aquí se está alejando de ti
así que esto de hecho va a ser ese es
antihorario así que es 3 r
y me fui muy rápido en esto así que te
recomiendo ver vídeos anteriores sobre
configuraciones absolutas en caso de que
hayas ido muy rápido para ti
ahora veamos veamos alcoholes cíclicos
sistemas de anillos así que veamos a un
alcohol con 6 carbonos en un anillo y
luego hay un o h saliendo de esta manera
así que 6 carbono sin hielo h lo
llamaríamos ciclohexano y ya que es un
alcohol solo cambiaremos eso a
ciclohexano esa es nomenclatura muy
simple
ciclo
exane hola
como esto de hecho no es necesario un
número pero podrías escribir un 1 ahí
pero no afecta que no lo pongas eso
sería ciclohexano
qué tal algo que tenga un sistema de
anillos
con dos grupos hidroxilo
digamos que tenemos también estéreo
química por lo que tenemos un h
saliendo hacia nosotros y luego digamos
que tenemos un h alejándose de nosotros
como esto muy bien así que cuando tienes
una situación como esta cuando tienes
dos alcoholes en la misma molécula tu
prefijos será de eso de hecho es dios y
la nomenclatura está basada en la
molécula de ciclohexano así que
escribirás
club
sano
y luego justamente después del ciclo
hexano es donde ponemos el
y hoy
y significa 22 alcoholes
tienes que especificar la posición de
estos dos alcoholes en el anillo así que
tienes así que continuaremos generando
el anillo digamos que este es el carbono
1 luego haremos a este el carbono 2
el carbono 3 el carbono 4 así que
tenemos alcoholes en las posiciones 1 y
4 así que escribiremos 1
4 aquí y la posición entre los dos
alcoholes es trans uno va hacia ti y el
otro se aleja de ti así que puedes
continuar y escribir y escribir
14 ciclohexano thion y ese es un nombre
correcto
bueno otros otros tipos de alcoholes
podemos tener en lugar de un anillo
ciclohexano
podemos tener un alcohol basado en el
anillo de benceno así que ponemos
nuestros enlaces pi de la siguiente
manera y si tenemos uno
h aquí
este es un tipo especial de alcohol
llamado fenol esta molécula se llama
fenol
y también verás esta verás esta porción
de la molécula hidroxi benceno en muchos
productos naturales esta es de hecho una
molécula muy importante para reconocer
fenoles ahora continuemos y pongamos
algo en este anillo así que continuemos
y tenemos nuestra base de fenol aquí
y agreguemos le agreguemos un bromo
aquí
así que como nombramos esa molécula
bueno la base de la molécula es la
molécula de fenol así que escribamos
fenol y luego tenemos que enumerar lo
así que el h ese debe de ser el carbono
1 y queremos darle a los sustituye entes
el menor número posible así que le
daremos a este carbono el número 2 así
que tenemos un bromo saliendo del
carbono 2 por lo que es razonable todo
lo que tenemos que hacer es escribir 2
bromo
así que tenemos dos bromo fenol como
esto así que esa es la nomenclatura para
alcoholes y para un tipo especial de
alcoholes llamados fenoles